[Music]
and psycho x news all this drink from
sip only machchar - mmm oh and this
Instagram page is so cool bar Quan check
it out say this Instagram page we are
sip know that I was the junk out of into
serious well I was huge lump on my shin
that's not a promo can you believe how
smooth delicious and perfectly sweet
this zip latte is I like it cuz it's
ice-cold unlike a piping hot dudes
armpits alright TIFF yep we know yeah
blueberry yeah she could turn any
talking point around she's that good I
told you watermelon better the crazy
thing is I'm lactose so it's both milk
so you won't diarrhea
alright it's Barbara it's pretty good
alright old milk
it's literally meat Oh God you got two
drinks no why do you ask that you don't
eat food at home this is one of my
favorite okay this is a fun one
submitted by everyday go to school to be
like that whoa look at this I have a
hematoma on my alright got problems we
get it you're a [ __ ] dude why do you
got in the world I'm gonna kick you in
your legs so hard
we're not you're gonna cry you always
have a brand deal with pain I'm
surprised I Scott hasn't hit me up once
dude with pain and disease yeah beer
tiger balm yeah this brought to you by
Salmonella yeah dude you should get
brandy dude I would kill her I see out
Commerce's you can tell people what
hospital go to that actually is up there
huh yeah have you ever walked down the
street and trip for no reason has my
back cuz I literally broke it do you
bleed like a [ __ ]
use this gauze
I'm David so I've lead like a [ __ ] boy
17-year old girls left sterilized after
she was assaulted with scalding hot
water from a shower hose sterilized or
does that mean that means she can know
if she can't have kids
oh she put that [ __ ] in her [ __ ] barrel
she didn't do it
she's assault assaulted with the shower
hose Wow
so what what how did that happen I'm
guessing they put it up inside her right
yeah
so this is Sarah 17 years old Sarah
started dating
yegor yegor is already an evil name you
waited for the you pause Egor does that
like I know you guys are gonna interrupt
me how was it let me guess an expert who
saved her from this attack right no
started date Oh
Egor is a [ __ ] because he left this
girl 17 year old who got pregnant by
Igor
he actually had sex concerning the
layers what countries is England Russia
[Music]
clearly look at me I don't behave I
don't abuse so Sarah didn't know that
ibaka alexandra pregnant when they
started dating
apparently like as soon as he found out
that Alexandra was pregnant he dumped
her and started a new relationship foxy
Wow damn all the girls in Russia are
[ __ ] hot both of those girls are cute
as [ __ ] yeah they're damn Russia 17
boyfriend and then the ex-girlfriend
they're cute though they are not two
girls that are cute what is going on
crush is [ __ ] that's what I say I won't
crush you but they will propose
that's the tender vibe that's what it is
I look gay but I crush [ __ ] yeah I'll
be [ __ ] up but not face don't let my
sweat their baby blue sweat their fool
you I only abuse vagina Alexandre got
this girl this girl this girl to go to
Sarah's house and attack her they
ransacked her house they stole money
they stole a laptop a phone as well as
other valuables they beat her they
forced her to give them oral sex which I
thought was weird Wow Wow they're very
open out there I guess yeah and they
filmed it all over thoughtful so police
have footage of this whole attack and
he's a different type of logic out there
now that's like me if I didn't like
someone and it's a guy and like I'm a
burglar I zone and then have him suck my
dear
Thank You van I wasn't sure frankly
where it was but you just I just have to
say it out loud because it's funny when
it was funnier out loud yeah shit's
crazy what the book yeah they also took
turns on peeing on her they shaved her
head and they grabbed the the hoe the
shower hose they turned on the water
waited till till it was scalding hot
they shoved it up her that's so wild and
but why what what did she do she just
started dating a horse that's it yeah
whew was Igor doing all during all this
[ __ ] another girl remember he does
not abuse that's true only [ __ ] I had
it all wrong I thought it was Igor that
was doing the bad bags well he kind of
is probably on a [ __ ] dating app
while they're doing the show he's on a
bender in the Russian tender Rinder was
he there they don't mention yeah I mean
I did some pickle Perry he would have
just done anything do you mean some in
our [ __ ] so like who Wow
David trying to set up his own not me
like oh I got beat up four times today
test out puss I gotta say though those
clothes are or that's man [ __ ] right
there I've volunteered or quite
gangsters that's some quite gangster
[ __ ] like that's it that though these
little Russian girls are doing American
street thug stuff that's like some mob
[ __ ] to another level where they were
they're raping and [ __ ] their victims
and torturing them I know that's crazy
not only are they just burglarizing
they're taking it to another their
torture that's some sauce [ __ ] that was
it was that one looks the craziest to me
she was like mister Berger victim right
that looks like American Apparel I chose
this girl and this girl they're both 16
and this one's 20 what the [ __ ] they all
look just like she's the one that got
the [ __ ] licked
why does it look like they all did like
they all had like the victim no yeah had
the victim I wonder how it was done
y'all peed on her too like goddamn you
peeing on a girl really hard for other
girls not if she was laying I mean
there's a lot of
that's yeah but it's not as easy as a
guy because the guy just points it goes
bu Vanessa if you're standing up yeah
but see a girl has to like squat sit Oh
get over them and then do it right or
they just I just dribbles down no that's
why you guys have a cup that's why you
guys have the car you argue with me
[ __ ]
listen use my word please okay Matt
explain it to me well I'm not man
explaining to you I'm trying to get my
sentence off so I'm trying to ask you so
let me describe what I think it's like
your yeah you already said if it
dribbles off the side and I said no no
but I wasn't done yet but are you sure I
wasn't done yet
okay Venice way because I saw the thing
you know the girlfriend they go hike
they use the cup and so he could direct
the piece so I assume that's because if
you guys could just direct your your and
then why would you need the color yeah
we can't direct it is that it does come
out with high pressure key doesn't
dribble down if the girl is laying down
on the floor they probably just exactly
that's more work than a guy though it
was what I'm saying a guy just what's
not useless
yeah we're doing that but that's my
point that's all I'm saying David's
saying it's [ __ ] there's no way for
a girl yeah yeah that's alright I'm
saying for a girl to pee on another
girl's a lot more difficult so it's not
working it's messy for Jenna you know
you got to take remove because a guy
just whips it out zip I'm just picturing
all of them naked with what's smooth
jazz playing in the back it's like good
and if they were getting their [ __ ]
it's either that they're all naked or
there's one girl with clothes no there's
one naked girl and all the other ones
just have tops on yeah that's right and
they're walking around like toddlers
just [ __ ] pants
I want to read a police report written
by Joe
don't forget three local traders walking
around like toddlers with no pants on
don't forget this video brought to you
by SIP siblings and nephews and cousins
there's first if you have a toddler
they're always walking around with just
a shirt what why that's true not very
true all the time I bet you Isaac was
walking around with just a shirt
sometimes he always had a diaper
don't you I don't want him peeing and
pooping all over the floor yeah
sometimes I'm just saying this isn't
it's not a rare sight what I'm saying is
it pretty good but what about the beach
at the beach it's like no one has pants
on this video was not brought to you by
City at all whatsoever Syd was brought
here forcibly for no reason this is
nothing to do with this lovely company
of ours
sip they now have a new location check
it out all right so these girls everyone
except for the pregnant one are in
custody the pregnant ones on Homer house
arrest because she's pregnant I don't
want to go Russian they're all facing 15
years in prison
oh no they're gonna come out hardened
for ruining their inside just for dating
this dude that's all she did she just
date this dude must be really slow in
that part yeah apparently that
ex-girlfriend sent her a text saying
leave us alone or I will kill and bury
you
I wonder what the gangs are like if the
normal girls aren't like this who was
the pregnant chick she's Igor's ex goof
one of the attackers no she didn't go
she she did go she did she was there I
thought she sent the she sent down the
three she was there so they just
straight-up broke into her place she was
like the ringleader of them was she
holding her belly like that during the
whole process and she peed her pregnant
piss on her face how pregnant pee smells
really bad they all look so innocent
[Music]